hello everyone I'm Alicia Malone this is
fandango's in me Movie Guide and there
are so many MVS out this week but I want
to concentrate on two of them these two
movies are so brilliant so absorbing and
are definitely going to end up on my
best list of 2016 enough teasing Malone
okay fair enough let's get into it with
moonlight what stirs are you linking up
with a deadline you just drove down here
yeah
before I even get started with this one
I'm gonna put a big awards watch over
the top because this definitely deserves
it you may have heard me talking about
moonlight in my episode I did from the
Toronto International Film Festival but
just as a reminder moonlight is directed
by Barry Jenkins and it tells the story
of one man's life in three different
parts so first you start off with him as
a child then you jump to him as a
teenager and then jump again to him as
an older man and he is dealing with so
much stuff trying to find a father
figure his crack addict mother getting
beaten up at school and also battling
with figuring out his own sexuality at
some point you got to decide for
yourself who you don't let nobody make
that decision moonlight has this
dreamlike memory type quality and Barry
Jenkins has crafted a beautifully
understated yet still emotionally epic
and boundary-pushing story I've said
before that moonlight is kind of like a
meditation on masculinity and what I
mean by that is that it gently and
poetically explores the ideas of what it
means to be a man and the Box you're
supposed to fit into or the Act you're
supposed to play you know the strength
and the violence can sometimes be a mask
for what's really happening inside the
inner emotional turmoil
I'm seeing the UI name
moonlight is definitely hashtag Alicia
approves try to see it if it's playing
in your area because this is the kind of
small movie that absolutely deserves our
support I see you in like a decade it's
not what I expected
was respect
moving on to my other big recommendation
this week the handmaiden by the genius
park Genrich sorry your hater than me do
you want to merge you don't get everyone
what you know I said that so I would put
an awards watch over this one but
because it would end up in the Best
Foreign Language category at the Oscars
for that to happen it would need to be
submitted via South Korea as being their
official entry and South Korea have
chosen the age of Shadows as their
official entry so oh well I'm sure it's
way too controversial for the Academy
anyway because this is an erotic lesbian
gothic heist thriller Japanese Korean
movies
you don't dis assail you hit the garbage
machine guns are good at I'm exactly
sure
I saw this movie and can and the crazy
story kept me on the edge of my seat for
the full two hours and 45 minutes
it is also sumptuously sharp it's
gorgeous to look at almost fetish Leigh
filmed at some points and yes it is very
erotic so it definitely is r-rated don't
take your kids don't go with your
parents the two lead women are fantastic
and you know ever since sympathy for
Lady vengeance Park chan-wook has really
been focusing on these strong female
central characters and when I was at
Fantastic Fest I got to sit down with
the genius director himself so I wanted
to know why he's changed his focus to
women in the last few movies also by the
way I shot this interview myself so
apologies if it doesn't look that good
take it away what's that urgency Tina
will one family doesn't believe in a
stahma make a comeback was filmed by
gamma
sang-doo design available war is he
going to my dad was a great rapport to
one gentleman I've never seen anything
from James oncological Patti thing gonna
go a double character on your song
advising me to get him up
can I get a woof-woof No
okay then so to recap my picks this week
are the emotionally satisfying moonlight
by Barry Jenkins all the twists speak
Korean thriller the handmaiden by Park
chan-wook and stay tuned to the very end
of this episode to see my other three
favorite films by Park chan-wook all of
these are available on Fandango now for
you to watch at home
I'm Alicia Malone I'll see you next week
bye